salut youtube c'est la 183e vidéo ce qui
veut dire que je suis à la moitié de mon
défi puisque cette année 2007 j'avais
décidé de faire une vidéo par jour du
1er janvier au 31 décembre dans cette
vidéo j'ai une grosse surprise pour vous
mais déjà j'aimerais vous remercier
d'être là depuis le début ou depuis pas
très longtemps merci également à tous
les youtube heures les youtube et ce
qu'ils m'ont invité sur leur chaîne et
ce qui fait plaisir c'est que pour fêter
la moitié du défi les acteurs du youtube
games ont envoyé un message vidéo j'ai
reçu plein de messages aujourd'hui et je
vais les découvrir en même temps que
vous et pour fêter ce genre spécial g3
annonce à faire aux abonnés je voulais
dit à la fin de la vidéo on se retrouve
après je voyais me défie la team menthe
à l'eau fabien olicard on est sympa
qu'un mec sympa mais un peu énervant si
on appuie son truc là oui ça en l'air
ouais ça m'a insupportable insupportable
ouais je sais fallu dire un truc sympa
mais bon c'est sur moi c'est terminé sur
ce que tu veux mais ça pour dire que
j'adore la chaîne de famille on dit car
je construis c'est vraiment une scène
géniale c'est un mentaliste nous apprend
plein de trucs que c'est vraiment trop
bien et moi ta main trick vachement je
fais quoi je pense à 16 oui c'est
ensuite le fard à paupières qu'on olic
olicard août
si j'étais tout à fait honnête avec toi
je dirais tu as l'air un petit
fatigué quand même tu as pas besoin de
vacances soi sur la haine des bissextile
fallait le faire quand même une vidéo
par jour pendant un an
c'est pas possible qui peut faire ça je
veux dire j'ai compris qu'en mais ça y
est le mec est mentaliste
non mais forcément il nous a tous
embrouiller l'esprit c'est la même vidéo
qui passe tous les jours et nous on
niveau tu veux on a l'impression que
c'est une nouvelle vidéo à chaque fois
et bien oui mais voilà forcément nos
maisons vides ou bonjour je suis un
poulet je veux remettre une petite
couche là aujourd'hui
vite fait bosser pour ceux déguisés ont
fabien olicard là comme ça va tu on
pourra faire la vidéo à ta place
quand on trouvera un truc donc pour ça
c'est pas compliqué papier crayon
rhodoïd feutre
voilà on a fait l'autre sur nos lits
maintenant on vient se placer comme il
faut on se place comme ça et voilà
maintenant on peut faire du fabien
olicard sur youtube il ya 183 jours
fabien olicard est venu me parler de
d'un concept qui voulait mettre en place
et une vidéo par jour pendant un an
honnêtement
bah ouais c'est j'avais très envie d'y
croire mais je me dis que pendant un an
c'est vraiment chaud et 7 ans foire est
elle pas il est à 6 mois de vidéos bravo
fabien je t'embrasse
la vidéo est ce que je t'ai dit je suis
tout ce qui va dans les cas c'est qu'il
avait flingué à la mort dati qui est
voiture vers toutes ces vidéos patrons
tous ces kilos prochain mental et c'est
moi qui vous c'est moi et surtout non un
petit salaire
salut fabien olicard c'est le message
fabien olicard donc content mon courage
c'est moi qui vais te mentaliser kivu
mentaliser vous qui regardez cette vidéo
je vais forcer votre esprit à penser à
un mot précis et uniquement en vous
jouant quelques notes de guitare c'est
parti hélas si vous pensez vous avez
rang de maître un pouce en l'air
non mais franchement en famille j'ai pas
bien suivi des cours de mentalisation
aller c'est quand geste ouvertement
papier d'alu j'ai du papier suffit que
tu sais bien catho papier d'alu qui
marche
tu vas tomber mais j'avais des enfants
je te rappelle que protéger sa tête avec
du papier d'aluminium est le seul
rempart fiable pour protéger ses pensées
de fabien olicard ça c'est du papier
suffit pas il n'y a que dans trois
heures ça le temps je ressens maison
dans son la cci épater les citations
très bien félicitations d'avoir réussi à
berner tout le monde pendant une demi
année je crois les tutelles et bien je
les aime bien
je vais pas l'oublier tu peux faire mais
le fou c'est bon tu peux y aller car la
milesse gad petite vidéo de tourner je
suis dans une ville c'est un petit peu
galère on s'emmerde un peu c'est le
virus passe pas grand chose à voir fuite
pour te faire une petite vidéo
je t'embrasse beaucoup
captain aux arêtes aboyer s'te plaît m'a
dit je veux absolument que toi tu fasses
un passage le voyage à tahiti kinois je
laisse les filets va bien se souvenir un
jour qu'il ne doit ce voyage à tahiti
donc s'il te plaît allez c'est parti
allez rire 3 2 1 et salut voila il perd
fier de mon pote fabien olicard 183
vidéo déjà à vraiment faux faut vraiment
avoir rien à [ __ ] de sa vie ouais et
ça profite d'une aide sociale alors à
l'eau elle est belle la france
oui une vidéo par jour c'est que j'ai
été le premier à être au courant ça
devait être au mois de décembre quand il
a balancé ce truc un petit petit peu
tard et puis à temps il a fait six mois
mais c'est bout du monde je pense que
moi je lui donne jusqu'au mois d'août il
passait franchement ils passent pas les
deux pouces en l'air mais quelle vidéo
pleine de sympathie je me demande ce que
je veux recevoir le 31 décembre à la fin
du défi alors déjà je n'arrêterai pas
les vidéos je continuais prochaine sur
une autre forme on aura le temps d'en
parler dans l'autre partie de l'année je
me suis lancé un grand défi pour les
cinquante mille abonnés je pensais pas
qu'on approchera aussi vite c'est génial
si vous voulez en savoir plus allez voir
la vidéo numéro 100 j'explique tout
dedans
la semaine prochaine je vais également
lancé un jeu sur la chaîne pour
mentaliser la ou l'une d'entre vous
mentalisation d'abonnés comme j'avais
déjà fait ici et surtout recevoir toutes
ces vidéos ça m'a donné une idée si vous
voulez m'envoyer une vidéo vous faites
une vidéo qui avait juste pour thème la
moitié du défi ça peut être quelque
chose de gentil ça peut être quelque
chose d'ironique ça peut être une
moquerie ça peut être complètement
décalé ça peut être complètement hors
sujet vous prenez votre téléphone et
vous la mettez sur instagram ou sur
facebook ou sur twitter en tout cas à
chaque fois attaqué moi bien dedans vous
avez tous mes réseaux dans le descriptif
si vous le faites sur facebook tag est
bien la fanpage c'est toute la semaine
prochaine je vais relayer les vidéos que
j'aurais trouvé le plus sympa ou plus
drôles ou comme ça les coups de coeur je
sais que bien souvent vous êtes
surprenant j'ai hâte de voir tout ça on
attaque la deuxième partie de l'année
cet été il va y avoir des choses mais je
suis en train de caler plein de
changements plein d'évolution à partir
de septembre
j'ai hâte de vous parler tout ça merci à
vous tous de la team mentale odette là
n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les
commentaires ce que vous aimeriez voir
dans les prochaines vidéos
si vous voulez me fais tu es un très
joyeux
moitié des filles vous pouvez faire
exploser littéralement le compteur des
pouces en l'air
abonnez-vous si ce n'est pas déjà fait
vous pouvez également abonnés vos amis
puisque le pantalon blog c'est une vidéo
par jour pendant un an et c'était la
moitié rendez vous demain à 17h ciao